be familiar with Moore's Law it's actually not a law so much it is an observation the law part is a little
tongue and cheek in my opinion the max number of transistors in an integrated circuit basically a computer chip
doubles about every 2 years over the past 5 decades or so we've not only observed this but have made great use of
it with more transistors we can perform more faster computations this is essentially what is responsible for
making computers more and more powerful and smaller Over time however there's some bad news Mo's law law is dying
experts disagree about when Mo's law will come to its eventual end but some say it already has although we may not
be exactly sure when we will reach our limit we know that it is eventually inevitable because some transistor Parts
cannot be made physically any smaller you can't make a transistor that is smaller than an atom for instance this
is of course completely unphysical sounds silly but those are the limits that we're actually working with so what
will we do just give up and say hey that's as good as it gets no humans have never done that luckily quantum
mechanics has entered the conversation quantum mechanics was discovered in the 1920s and since then the world has
literally never been the same and we could spend hours talking about the revolutionizing discoveries that were
made but that's not really the focus of this course instead I want to make it clear that we know that quantum
mechanics and Computing are already compatible with with one another the findings and understandings of nature
that we learned from quantum mechanics have in part made our modern-day computers possible without quantum
mechanics we would not understand or probably have even been able to invent the solid state hard drive for
example Quantum computation is simply the next natural step in this Evolution
but computation doesn't just exist in a vacuum information requires a medium
computing information harnesses the physical world and it affects it as well this places limitations on what is even
physically possible but understanding nature and the physical limitations is actually the aim of physics as a
discipline so in a way physics and computation have always been intertwined Ralph Landau a computer scientist and an
ibmr recognized decades ago that information is physical putting it another way information is not an
abstract entity but exists only through physical representation landow's principle establishes a connection
between information and the laws of thermodynamics but in fact there are many connections between physics and
computation classical physics was all we were able to explore up until recently but with the discovery of quantum
mechanics we are now on the precipice of being able to create an entirely new way to compute and this is great because
classical computers can only approximate what actually occurs in nature and in some cases that approximation is very
limited that's because it's really really hard to get machines that follow the laws of classical physics to
approximate the laws of quantum physics and nature is not classical it is quantum one analogy that might help you
understand is a wind tunnel fluid dynamics are notoriously hard to simulate and predict mathematically
even something as mundane as a car driving through some wind car manufacturers found that it was actually
too costly and impractical to try to simulate this physical interaction when they were designing cars instead what
they ended up doing is creating a literal tunnel that blows wind through it and just drive a car into the tunnel
and see how it performs this is analogous to what I mean when I say classical computers only poorly
approximate nature and sometimes it's too costly to even attempt to have them do it instead of simulating the wind
researchers just recreate it similarly quantum computers don't have to approximate the laws of nature on a
molecular level because they follow those laws intrinsically they don't have to simulate anything they emulate it and
the same difficulties arise when we're simulating batteries or chemical reactions which leads us to our next
section Quantum Computing what is it good for so
why would we even want to think about combining quantum mechanics and Computing well there are already plenty
of problems that are too difficult too computationally costly for even our cuttingedge supercomputers to solve
maybe these are problems that only researchers are super focused on but their impacts could touch all parts of
the globe these problems that classical computers get stuck on are things that we as a Society are becoming more and
more reliant on technology for and really care about like battery efficiency Financial modeling and
optimization and even how to build better planes so why turn to quantum computers well we have very good reasons
to think there's a lot of potential here and we can open doors to new computation that is currently Out Of Reach for even
the most powerful supercomputers in theory some Quantum algorithms provide advantages over the
best possible classical algorithms for some applications for other applications there is mounting evidence that even
with some noise and Imperfections quantum computers can still be used as a tool to compete with classical brute
force solutions basically it is a brand new tool and we want to figure out even more cool things we can do with it but we can
also look to Fan's original idea for them which is to use them to understand physics and nature in and of itself
after all I already told you that nature is quantum not classical and this field is incredibly Rich fascinating and
interdisciplinary it brings together physics computer science information processing and of course the specific domains of application areas that we
might be interested in however unlike classical computers not everyone has a quantum computer sashed away in their
back pocket until very recently if you wanted to experiment with a quantum computer you had to build and maintain
one yourself usually in a sad basement lab in a university or research facility and trust me I would know no longer is
this the case however in 2016 IBM put the first Quantum processor on the cloud it had only five cubits at the time and
fairly High rates of errors but that was only 8 years ago and look at how far we've come so where do we stand today
there are a lot of parallels to be drawn to the very early days of the modern computer like I mentioned this is a very
hard Challenge and it was only within the last 8 years that quantum computers became widely available besides for
those who are working in a Cutting Edge lab or facility but in those past eight years we have made progress on every